es el quinto presidente de Cuba después
de 1959 el primero en dirigir los
destinos de La Isla después de Fidel y
Raúl Castro el ascenso de Miguel
díaz-canel fue notable al punto de ser
elegido por Raúl Castro y votado por la
asamblea nacional tuvo que ganarse el
respeto del pueblo y su primer mandato
estuvo lleno de dificultades que
marcaron la historia reciente de Cuba la
caída de un avión de pasajeros en 2018
el paso de Huracanes devastadores una
pandemia que devastó a la industria
turística y una grave crisis económica
que golpea al pueblo
nació los mejores porque son más corría
explosiones por la del saratorios la
pandemia entonces creo que él ha querido
darlo de él lo que pasa que las
condiciones como que han ido en contra
pero no es que no tenga como si Deseo
ver el país adelante una situación que
desató en julio de 2021 las protestas
más grandes registradas contra el
gobierno nos va a tomar las calles
derivaron en condenas criticadas por la
comunidad internacional
el peso de la del disjusto de la
molestia de la impopularidad que causa
el problema económico pero Bajo su mando
se cuentan varios éxitos como el
enfrentamiento científico y social a la
pandemia y la aprobación de un nuevo
código de familias que permite la unión
oficial de dos personas del mismo sexo
en Cuba no hay ni habrá giros
capitalistas sin embargo se han aprobado
varias reformas constitucionales y
económicas aunque los ciudadanos piden
una mayor apertura
nuestra nosotros los que poblamos esto y
de los que nos dirijanel debe lograr más
del 50% de los votos en una asamblea de
470 diputados de lograrlo enfrentará
según la Constitución su último mandato
de cinco años sin un relevo a la vista
lo que abre desde ya la puerta a una
pregunta clave entre los cubanos quién
lo suce